what began with fulsome praise from the
president there would be no on-the-job
training for Christian she is ready on
day one would you say good ended with a
perfunctory tweet president Trump giving
no reason for Nielsen's departure and a
bland expression of thanks for her
service Nielson rose to the position of
chief of Homeland Security in December
2017 and in just over a year in the job
she garnered criticism as the public
face of Trump's controversial
immigration policies such as that of
separating migrant children from their
parents at the us-mexican border a
policy she denied exists it's been much
outcry consternation and frankly
misinformation for many in the press in
Congress and advocacy groups over the
last few weeks that we at DHS are
intentionally doing things that are
unhu' manatorian that are cruel immoral
and disgraceful we aren't doing none of
those things in her letter of
resignation which was published online
she didn't mention her reasons for
leaving but observers see it as a sign
of conflicts in the White House as the
president's rhetoric on immigration
becomes increasingly strident our
Washington correspondent Michael Hager
says Nielsen's resignation comes as no
surprise that nielsen was finally forced
out it's no big surprise Trump was
unhappy that he couldn't stop the border
crossings at the US border with Mexico
especially from families with children
over the past two years
Trump was also very unhappy that he
could not get his money for the big
promised wall even though he instituted
the longest government shutdown in US
history
he's also very unhappy that he couldn't
continue his policy to separate migrant
children from their families because
public opposition was just too strong
and he's also very unhappy that he could
not close the border down over the past
week because public opposition again was
too strong especially from US businesses
and the face of all this all these
failed policies was Kirsten Nielsen his
Department of
man security secretary she was the face
of all those failed policies and Trump
needed a scapegoat right now and that's
why he decided to finally get rid of her
and force her out